syria's refugees a lost generation
this week in the interview we speak to
christolina giorgieva european
commissioner for humanitarian aid and
crisis response
commissioner
it's been described as the worst
humanitarian crisis of the 21st century
so far the crisis in and around syria
now i know that you know the region very
well and i know that you're in almost
daily contact with humanitarian partners
in the region what can you tell me about
the situation on the ground
it is terrible it is the worst crisis
that we have lived through in the
last decades and unfortunately it would
get even worse
we have
tremendous suffering of syrians in the
country
the world sees more the faces of the
refugees the 2 million people who fled
but 5 million have been displaced
internally
and when i think of what this crisis is
i don't see a face of a soldier or a
rebel it is the face of a child
half of the victims of of the syria
crisis
are children
i have talked to many of them
and the stories they they share
are stories that no child should ever
have to face
a six-year boy gave me a present a
drawing
of his memories from home from syria and
it was a drawing
of
a tank
blood
and the dead body of his young cousin
abdullah
in syria
for a first time in the last decades
civilians are targeted and killed
doctors are shot at and the world is
turning a blind eye that's one thing i
wanted to talk about because you're
talking here about the suffering and
hardship of the syrian people the
displaced people and the refugees but
there are also people in syria aid
workers relief workers who are trying to
get help to them tell me about how their
situation has become more difficult and
more dangerous
even the most experienced humanitarian
workers tell me
we have never seen anything so bad
they are shot at
a convoy
humanitarian goods
leaves damascus
and travels for 16 days
under sniper fire they get stopped
multiple times
arrested released
and that sometimes things are taken out
of the of the of the convoy
we lost 31 humanitarian workers in this
crisis actually a german humanitarian
worker just
saved his life running out of a
captivity
and that is where
in my hearts of heart
i am stunned that the united nations
security council has not yet
voted on a resolution to condemn killing
of civilians and the people who are
there to help well tell me the word used
there is stunned i think that's a very
interesting when you talk about that
you've mentioned yourself in the past
the paralysis as you've called it of the
united nations security council you've
dismissed the council and i'm quoting
you here as an institution of the past
completely anachronistic in the 21st
century those are strong words
the united nations security council
is there to guarantee peace in the world
well at any one point of time
there are 20 to 30 countries in conflict
slipping into a conflict coming out of a
conflict
in the case of syria this is the first
time
when the security council has not been
able
to unite around two very simple things
don't kill civilians don't kill the
people who are there to help it has
never happened before
and when
how how angry does that make you
personally because you know the
situation in syria and you're describing
blocking tactics by the russians
primarily by the chinese as well how
angry does that make you
it makes me mostly very sad for the
people who suffer it's not about me it
is about
those who need help and those who ask
day in day out a very simple question
how come the world is turning a blind
eye
on what is happening uh to us how can we
actually take
what you're saying is you're saying the
world is turning a blind eye to this
crisis does that i mean you the eu is
the eu turning a blind eye to the crisis
the humanitarian community including us
in the european union from day one we
have been leaning forward to help people
as much as possible we actually we
european leaning forward is an
interesting formulation we have
mobilized
extraordinary amounts of support for the
people in syria and for their neighbors
we speak today and it is 1.5
billion euros
for medicines and food and shelter
to victims of the crisis in syria
for safe space for children it sounds
like a lot of money is it enough money
because i mean you know these countries
especially the four immediate neighbors
of syria they're being absolutely pushed
to the limit as you know
in terms of uh humanitarian contribution
this is very significant look
every year the world spends between
seven and 12 billion euros in
humanitarian aid for some three to four
hundred million people who need help so
this is very significant but the needs
are growing and i can say we cannot
catch up
we have negotiated that 14 international
humanitarian organizations can operate
inside syria health a german
organization is one of them it would
have not happened without our active
participation but we also were the first
to say look at the neighboring countries
not only we have to help the refugees
we have to help the local communities
that are hosting them our latest
contribution from the commission
400 million euros 250 humanitarian aid
150
million for
jordanian and lebanese local communities
so we don't see
heated
uh
confrontation between refugees and local
people you've said uh in the in the very
recent past you've said because we're
talking here about money and obviously a
significant contribution is being made
here but you have said
money is not enough and many european
countries are now taking in refugees
from syria but germany for example is
taking and has begun to take in 5 000
refugees
now rights activists and opposition
figures have already said
it's a drop in the ocean
they're right aren't they they're right
well yes and no because for the moment
the syrian people what do they want they
want an end to this madness
so they can go home
i talk to
hundreds and hundreds of refugees
they actually
are not so much looking to come to
europe some young people want to come to
study in europe but majority they are
culturally more comfortable where they
are so helping jordan lebanon turkey
iraq
this is really important
those who want to come we have already
accepted
close to 50 000
people and i would say we will have to
do more we have to keep our hearts open
our wallets open and our borders open
because
what we europeans bring
is this
notion that solidarity in the world is
the only way to face the future of more
disasters and more more when you talk
about the future there it's interesting
because really we we've so far only
really talked about the here and now of
the syria crisis what about all the
traumatized children what about the
cities that have been ravaged by the
conflict who's going to help those
children in the future who is going to
rebuild the cities
thank you for bringing the question of
children because
what we are producing with this war is
not just suffering and loss of life but
a lost generation
and
focusing today
on how we can alleviate this loss
for the sake of children because this is
morally right to do but also for our own
sake
uh and what we can do is and and this is
where the european union i'm sure would
play a very decisive role is to bring
the world together
on
raising money but also designing
programs for the lost generation even if
the crisis ends tomorrow
there is peace
the wounds
it would take years and years and years
to heal
and just tell me this i know you you're
a very busy commissioner and i know that
you've been on the ground in crisis
situations in countries like haiti and
pakistan in chile i think in somalia
it's fair to say those experiences that
you've gathered elsewhere how have they
helped you to lead your team
in syria
well what i learned is
read the early signs of crisis
and
i will go back to this expression that
you picked up lean forward
act decisively
target the most vulnerable people
and always
be agile for changing circumstances
deploy your very best people in the most
difficult conditions and i can tell you
maybe the most important thing i learned
in this job is pray for the best
prepare for the worst
that's interesting because that's
exactly the point i was going to come to
as my final question when when you
because you said this is not about you
as a person but i'd like to know about
you as a person when you go to these
places that have been that have been
very hard hit by conflicts or natural
catastrophes natural disasters
how close do you sometimes perhaps come
to losing hope
you know i cannot afford that
because people there face much more
difficult time
and i bring them i bring them help but i
also must
bring them hope i i have to i have to
have it in my heart
there is one picture that i would carry
with me as long as i live
i was in my
home country playing with my
granddaughter she was 18 months very
healthy
young baby
from there i went to chat so from
bulgaria to chad from bulgaria to chat
and i walked in this room
full of children 40 at least
so severely malnourished
that that not only they cannot play and
laugh
they can't even cry and the
deafening silence in this room i would
never forget
and i and i had to smile to them because
that was
what i can bring in this room
hope
thank you for that and thank you very
much for talking to us today
commissioner